scp-99 also known as the Tickle Monster
is a safe class anomaly contained by the
SCP Foundation it appears to be a
gelatinous orange blob about the size of
a large dog scp-99 is a friendly and
sociable creature with a playful nature
and a strong desire to interact with
humans it has been observed to seek out
Personnel for play sessions using its
amorphous body to mimic human gestures
and expressions scp-99 has a unique
ability to secrete a powerful slime that
has several anomalous effects on those
who come into contact with it the Slime
is capable of inducing a sense of
euphoria and reducing stress as well as
healing physical injuries and curing
illnesses scp-99 is a highly valued
asset of the foundation and is often
used to improve the morale and mental
health of personnel any breach of
containment by scp-999 is to be handled
with caution as its slime can neutralize
other anomalies and pose a significant
threat to the foundation's containment
protocols